欢迎你学习白泽 国际站运营实战系统课 同学们 第三小节我们来讲一下关于怎样持续的迭代自己的运营技能不断的突破
这里主要是讲一种关于运营学习的方法 一种高效的学习方法 这是方法中的方法
如果我们不去重视提升自己运营学习的能力 那么我们是很难快速的去迭代出新的方法
很难去适应平台这么快速的变化的 因为平台可能一周或者是一个月 他就会更新迭代的一些规则
或者是一些新的运营方向 所以你必须拥有非常强的学习能力 才能够更快的去迭代更新自己的运营支持库
才能够更加快的把自己所学到 或者是说所领悟到的新变化 新方法 应用到我们的店铺当中
从而快速取得更好的运营成绩 那么我们先来讲一下 关于高级运营技能的一个
学习方法是怎么样的 第一个就是自主学习 第二个就是学习的局道
第三个就是一定要去构建你的运营思维体系 因为这个最终才是你最核心的底层的一些框架
去支撑你整个技能的学习和演变的方法 首先第一个我们来看一下关于自主学习
因为知识是不断更新迭代的 每个人的认知都是有局限性的
通过不断的吸收新的知识 与我们自身原有的知识发生到化学反应
才能够碰撞出新的认知和新的方法
迭代旧的认知 把我们零散的知识
板块融合在一起 构建出一个更加全面的知识体系
快速的输出我们新的思路和新的方法
所以自主学习是非常重要的 一定要重视自主学习
比如说我们在店铺的运营中 每周
或者是每天 可能是下班前30分钟 或者是一个钟
就开始进行
学习
部分
新的内容
第二个就是
学习局道
我们一定要知道
国际站有哪些学习的局道
这样有利于我们快速的获取高价值的信息
以及高价值的一些方法
比如说第一个就是国际站后台小合问答
如果你对于某些
比较简单或者是概念的问题不是特别清楚
那么你直接可以在后台去问小合就可以了
这样的话就能够把你所有知识的盲区
通通的解决掉
第二个就是我们
国际站后台都有很多指标
后面会有一个问号
那么你通过这个问号
鼠标点击一下
就会出现一些概念你去把这些概念理解了
如果你不理解
又返回来问小合就可以了
第三个就是
外贸
云课堂 这些课堂里面的
课程呢可能很多都是旧的 如果没有新的你就没必要看 你可以看一些新的就可以了
第四个就是一些官方的直播课 有些课
其实就是纯属的浪费时间 如果你已经懂了 没必要看
如果一些比较新颖的课
或者是说
一些比较有价值的课
那么你可以去看一下
去
学一下新的思路和新的思维 因为有些时候别人的一些思路和方法
能够给你更多的启发 去衍生新的思路和新的方法
第五个就是运营交流群 你要进那些群的时候 千万不要去闲聊
尽可能的去
捕捉一些高价值的信息
群就是为了获取信息的
同时呢 通过
看别人分享的方法
去思考
我能不能用这种方法到我的店铺
同时呢
我去看别人所问的这些问题 我看看我是不是能够
解决这些问题 或者是我有没有什么方法去解决这些问题
这样去学习都能够提升我们的
综合的
知识
技能
第六个就是官方的公告 这些的话
主要就是平台一些趋势啊 或是一些功能产品的
更新迭代会出现一些公告
可以看一下
第三个就是去构建我们运营思维体系 怎么去构建的
第一个
我们前面也讲了 一定一定要重视运营基础
提出知识概念
越是简单的东西 越是有价值
第二个就是一定要去构建一些测试的模型 比如说你想测试一样东西 那么你就去思考
怎么样去测试 然后怎么样去判断
这些结果是否
被验证
不断的总结
把这些实操
高效的方法
复盘总结出来
总结出来呢
如果是非常有用的方法 那么你就开始
把这些方法
复制沿用到
其他的板块
那么就可以了
这样就能够把你这个
最高效的方法的结果放大
第四个呢
我们
国际站后台是不是会有非常非常多的
板块
我们要去思考的就是他们
各个板块之间有哪些关联或者
这些关联
有什么样的作用
我们这样去思考
才能够
更快的掌握各个板块的
关联性以及
联合的应用方法
第五呢我们就要适当的去阅读一些与流量有关运营相关的一些书籍
这些书籍不一定说能够具体的指导你怎么样去操作店铺
但是呢他里面的一些
新的
运营思路
思维
或者是一些
新的
操作方法
都能给你一定的
启发
去
衍生出
属于
或者是更加符合
我们自己店铺运营的方法
这都是非常有价值的
所以呢
我们要想提升自己的
运营技能
成为一个更加值钱的运营
那么我们就必须要
不断的去更新迭代
自己的
运营知识和不断的去
衍生出新的方法
新的
思路
希望这节课能够帮你打开一些关于学习的一些新的思路
那么接下来我们就开始
行动起来吧
按照这种方式不断的去学习
不断的去提升
我相信
你一定能够在更短的时间内
实现自己的目标
好了
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见